hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of Jax diffusers
um Jacks diffusers kickoff events and
today we are going to host the team
Suraj and Sabrina
and without further Ado I would like to
have Tim team is working in Google brain
and today he is going to talk about
efficient image and video generation
with distilled diffusion models
the floor is yours
thanks thanks for the intro
right so for today I will actually talk
about basically six different papers
that collaborators and I have written
over the past two years
so this is Joint work with lots of great
colleagues at Google and I'm very
grateful to them for all their amazing
work of course it's quite a little bit
of material so I'll just give a very
high level overview hopefully you'll
know where to find the good bits after
this talk and of course I can answer
more detailed questions also after
[Music]
to set the stage and reflect upon what
an amazing year has really been for
generative modeling so I've been in this
field for a while now and I think the
past year has really been here
generative modeling so at Google we
released imagine an imagining video two
models that I was involved in but also
for Nike is another epigl model that we
released and a party a text to image
model and of course outside of Google we
had tally 2 and stable diffusion all
basically within one year
um
and we really came quite far in the
years before so when I got started in
these fields in 2013 2014 we just had
feas be invented and Gans and what it
barely works if you look at the samples
on the left here you can't really make
out what we're generating
um so then we made some advances in Auto
regressive models
MSL was at open AI at the time and I had
this opportunity to present some of my
work to Elon Musk and I actually showed
them these particular samples right here
well needless to say he was not very
impressed
um but fortunately we made a lot of
progress as a field since then
in 2019 I think we made a big step with
big can where for the first time we were
really able to synthesize compelling
images still in a very limited data set
imagenet where we had specific classes
and corresponding images
um and then again but then in the past
year really is for the first time we're
able to take basically arbitrary tax
descriptions of what we want to generate
and then generate truly compelling
images at high resolution
um so for Imagine specifically I want to
tell you a bit more about the system the
way it works and what it can do
um it's at a high level it's a text to
image model when you put in a string
like sprouts and shape or text imagine
coming out of a fairy tale book and out
comes a 1K or 1K pixel a high resolution
image with quite a bit of intricate
detail as you can see here
um it can do amazing things like
spelling and also composition so here
we're asking for a transparent sculpture
of a duck made out of claws in front of
a painting of a landscape and it
actually gets all these corrects and
knows how to compose those into a
coordinate image
and it can even do this when you put in
things that it probably has never seen
in training at least not in this
combination like a photo of a rainbow
called a cow floating in the space above
Earth milk away in the background
um it can even generate objects that
cannot exist in the Real Worlds like
this coffee cup
or it can generate objects that we would
not like to exist in real world because
they would be very flexible
um so there's a number of things that go
into imagine that make it possible and
there's four main parts there's the data
so the model itself is trained on close
to a billion text image pairs so really
quite a large scale
the model itself is based on diffusion
models of course but we combine them
into something we call a Cascades so
it's a combination of different models
it also relies heavily on Frozen text
models so large language models
um and we there's also some advances in
how we sample from this model so we use
classifier free guidance and we have a
number of tricks to maximize the text
alignments between the image we generate
and the text prompts and then of course
we apply this at quite a large scale
which is necessary to get the best
possible results
so I'll say a little bit more about
these three aspects cascading the text
models and the classifier free guidance
so at the basis the diffusion model that
we all know and love it turns Pure Noise
into an image but we compose it in a
pipeline so the first stage of the
pipeline we take the text prompt we
embed it into effective space using a
frozen language model so it's not
trained
and get out a set of embeddings
um the first diffusion model then takes
the embeddings and some input noise and
turns it into a low resolution image
the second diffusion model takes the
embeddings and the lower resolution
image and up samples it to a higher
resolution image and we do this once
more to get to our final results
and there's some tricks to make this
work for example you need to have some
augmentation whenever you train these
super resolution models so that they are
robust enough to actually work at test
time and we have a number of details on
that in the paper and taking all taking
it all together this is a very effective
way of generating high resolution images
of the highest quality
um one other very important trick that
we use in this model is called guidance
so in the diffusion model what we do is
we have noisy data which I denote by XT
here and maybe a class label or a text
bronze why so in this case y might be
the label of dog
and this gets and then we feed this to a
model that tries to denose this to the
clean image that I denote by X naught
here
um however in practice what we often do
is we parameterize the model in such a
way that we actually predict the noise
rather than the image itself
so this is can be thought of as a
residual parameterization
and this noise estimate actually turns
out to be proportional to the gradient
of the log density of the image given
the textual description or the label
um openai a whole bunch of folks at open
AI in 2021 then came up with this this
great trick to modify the prediction of
the Noise by adding in the gradient of a
classifier model so the classifier model
takes in the noisy image predicts a dog
or some other class and then what you do
is you move the noisy data in the
direction of the class that you want to
generate so this ensures that you're
generating something that's well aligned
with the text prompt
um we did some follow-up work on this
using a technique that we call
classifier free guidance where instead
of an explicit classifier or use an
implicit classifier using base rule so
we say the probability of the label
given the data is proportional to the
probability of the data given the label
divided by the unconditional probability
of the data
so if we take that implicit classifier
we take the log gradient again
and then we get this other term which is
the difference between the gradients
with respect to X of the log density
given the label and the gradient of the
log density
um in conditional of the data of the of
the prompt
and this difference you add into the
estimate of the noise and this works
quite well
um in practice we predict noise so when
you plug in the noise prediction rather
than the gradient estimates that looks
like this so we have a noise prediction
conditional on the text prompt and one
in conditional and in practice we do do
that by simply training one conditional
model that always takes in embedding for
the text prompts but sometimes we set
this to zero so we just encode the zero
string and this we take to be the
unconditional prediction of the image or
the noise
so this trick works quite well in
ensuring that what we generate
corresponds to the text
um so here I'm showing you the results
for a number of different settings for
this uh this W parameter and guidance
on the y-axis I have FID so FID is a
matter a measure of how well
our model is capturing the data
distribution and on the x-axis I have
the clip score so clip scores a measure
for how well what we generate actually
represents the text prompt that we asked
for
so as we increase the guidance weight we
move from the bottom left of this image
to the top right so initially both FID
and clip score improve and then as we
increase guidance further FID starts to
deteriorate so what we generate is
further removed from the data
distribution then for the null guidance
case
but the alignment is still improving
and what we find in practice is that
users often care more about the
alignments than about the Fidelity with
which we capture the underlying data
distribution
so when we combine this with some tricks
where we do some clipping or
thresholding to make the model stable
this this results in a red line here
where we can get very high clip scores
and this corresponds to Generations that
or images that the users find very
compelling
um for the text model we investigate
different classes of text encoders we
look at language models like D5 and
birds and we also look at texting
encoders from image to text models like
clip and we actually find that these tax
only models they actually work very well
which is kind of surprising since they
never even saw visual data during
training
um so we take these language models and
we freeze them so we don't train their
parameters and we still find that their
representation actually is very useful
for generating images
and in particular what we find is that
larger text models give us
representations of texts that are more
useful or that the model finds easier to
use in generating images
and we actually find that using the
largest text models actually makes a
large difference for the perceptual
quality of the images that we can
generate
um so for us after having done Imagine
The Next Step kind of logical Next Step
was to ask whether we could do the same
for video and it turns out what we can
so we have this follow-up project called
imagine video and where we generate
short five second clips of video
um
in much the same way as we do text
conditions images in Imagine
um like I imagine for images imagine
video is a really a pipeline of
different models so we once again start
with a text prompt that we feed into a
large language model D5 XXL in this case
so that's the yellow box that you see
here
after that we think it's embedding and
we feed it into the first diffusion
model which is these in the blue box
it's a a base model that generates a
very low resolution video so in this
case just 16 frames at a resolution of
40 by 24.
um so for about five seconds that's at
three frames per seconds
after that we then up sample this low
resolution video in multiple stages so
in all the red boxes that you see in
this graph we do temporal super
resolution meaning that we increase the
frame counts of the video and on all the
green boxes what we do is spatial super
resolution so there we increase the
um the pixel counts or the the
resolution of the the frames of the
video
so we do this six times to arrive at our
final output which is five seconds of 24
frames per second video at high
resolution
um so I'll give you some examples of
what it looks like later
the mole itself at each of these stages
is really quite a simple diffusion model
in a previous paper we introduced this
model that we call a video diffusion
model and it's really it's kind of the
the the smallest Delta we can make from
the image model
um so basically what we're saying is
that a video is is kind of like an image
you just have one additional dimension
in the tensor and similarly what we do
is we take the standard to the unit that
we used for images and we just apply it
to each of the frames in a video and we
add some additional layers that exchange
information across time so it's a
standard unit with some additional
attention layers that exchange
information between the frames
so here's one example of something we
can generate with this and here we ask
for a bunch a bunch of autumn leaves
falling on the lake to form the text
imagine video
and quite amazingly it can both do the
spelling and it can also get the timing
right so here's another example
so what I find quite amazing about these
examples is that it comes with the
spelling but it also gets the timing
exactly right so
the text actually starts appearing at
the start of the video and completely
finishes uh appearing at the end of the
video and this is actually not really
Cherry picks we can quite generate this
quite consistently
um although there's nothing in a model
that actually tells it that it needs to
take exactly five seconds to generate
this and there's nothing in the training
data either
um so really the magic that actually
allows this to happen is guidance
um so in guidance we ask the model to
generate something that aligns well with
the text prompt within the span of time
that we give it and the only way it can
do this is by actually matching up the
text appearing with the duration of the
video
and this is also quite quite unique to
this wave generating where I regenerate
all the frames at the same time if you
would do something also regressive where
you would generate one frame at a time
it's much more difficult to get the
model to actually understand this timing
without explicitly telling it that the
video is five seconds or that the C
needs to be completed by a certain
number of frames
and here's some more examples I can do
things that are out of distribution like
a wooden figurine surfing on the
surfboard in space
um another out of distribution example
on a happy elephant wearing a birthday
hat walking under the seat
and here's a very cinematic one flying
through an intense battle between
Pirates ships in a stormy ocean
and the last one I feel for Castle so
um it's actually great at doing these
aerial shots and there's a lot of Drone
footage in the data I think
and yeah I find these very nice also
um of course we also evaluate our models
on a number of standard benchmarks and
especially for the base video diffusion
model
um so here we look at ucf101 which is a
benchmark for unconditional generational
video and there we find that we get a
very very good results in terms of both
FID and Inception score so here FID is
um again captures the how accurately we
represent the data distribution and
Inception scores
more related to alignment similar to the
clip score I showed you earlier and on
both we do quite well
and we can also do video prediction so
in video prediction we actually get the
first frame of a video or the first
couple frames and the task is we need to
play out a video from the starting point
so predict where the scene is gonna go
how things are going to develop and the
most well known Benchmark here is this
rubber pushing tile Square you get lots
of videos of this robot arm moving
around and your task is to predict how
it will interact with the objects and
what will happen
um so there we do quite quite well
um another video prediction task is
kinetics so kinetics is a collection of
videos like you might encounter on
YouTube
um of people performing various actions
and also there with the predictions work
quite well especially if we use more
fancy sampling methods like lunge event
diffusion
I'll talk about I'll say a bit more
about that later
um
so I've showed you what these models can
do in
practice or at least if you're willing
to take some time and maybe do some
cherry picking and try out a number of
things
but it doesn't mean that this really
makes for a very compelling user
experience because naively sampling a
video currently takes about 10 minutes
slightly more for a five second video
which means that if you're interacting
with this system uh you know it gets
boring very quickly
so I strongly believe that generated
models need to be very fast in order to
be practically useful
you have limited patients as a user you
want the system to be interactive and so
the systems need to be fast
our Solutions we make these models
faster is to distill diffusion models
into models that take much fewer
sampling steps and we typically go down
to four to eight sampling steps without
losing much quality
um we developed this technique in two
papers Progressive distillation were
fast sensing of diffusion models so I
clear paper and a more recent cvpr paper
and that's on archive for reading and
will be featured at the next cvpr
and what we find is that if you apply
these techniques to the imagining video
samples that I showed you you can
actually generate these in about 30
seconds which I think is just about the
amount of time that is that you're still
willing to wait and where you can still
try out different problems and interact
with the system
we also have some open source codes that
demonstrates the the basics Behind These
algorithms it's all written in Jax so it
should play nicely with all the other
stuff that you're building and
experimenting with
so before I explain how exactly we do
this distillation I want to say a little
bit more about how we actually sample
from diffusion models in the first place
so here on the left you see the standard
view which is that sampling is done by
assimilating a stochastic interferential
equation so we get this this noise from
a known starting distribution like a
gaussian and then we simulate this
stochastic process that gradually takes
us into the direction of the data
which is much more as a much more
complicated distribution so what does
that looks like is we gradually turn
noise into the clean image and we do
that by simulating the stochastic
differential equation at the bottom here
but it turns out that actually there's
an equivalent view where we have very
smooth and deterministic paths from the
initial random noise to the data
distribution and these parts are given
by something that's called the
probability flow ode or the ordinary
differential equation which is given at
the bottom here
so here there's no noise term it's a
deterministic process that we can
actually compute exactly if we have
enough time
turns out you can rewrite the stochastic
differential equation to make it more
similar to the ode so here I've split
out in the green boxes the deterministic
parts and then the remaining parts is
language event Dynamics
so what this basically says is that both
the stochastic way of sampling from
these models and the deterministic way
are basically the same thing the only
thing you get in addition when you do
the stochastic sampling is some
additional mixing
um
according to the data distribution using
an mcmc algorithm like language of an
Dynamics
so it's this green box that we can
actually help to distill so the green
box is something you can integrate for a
number of steps and then it gives you a
deterministic mapping from one point of
the the input noise to something along
the direction to the the outputs image
and this deterministic mapping is
something that we can hope to represent
with the neural net that takes fewer
steps than the sulfur that we use to
actually generate the path
um so that's what we actually distill
um so in order to do this efficiently we
propose an algorithm called Progressive
distillation
where we apply this distillation in
multiple stages and at each stage we
take a student model that is warm
started from a teacher model just by
making a copy
and it learns to imitate the teacher
model but it actually uses half as many
sampling steps so what that looks like
is something like this on the left here
on the left here
you see a teacher model that takes four
steps
and what we do is each of these two for
two steps we try and distill that into a
student model that does the same thing
but with only one step
so the first two steps get distilled
into something that takes one step to
get to the same point the second two
steps get distilled into something that
also takes one step
and now at the next stage we take this
new student model and we turn it into
the teacher model we repeat this for
this process we now go from two steps
into one step
and so you can imagine if you start out
this way with many steps you can
iteratively half the number of steps
required and this works quite well in
practice and it's very computationally
efficient
so looking at the algorithm it looks
like this so on the left is the standard
diffusion training codes and on the
right is Progressive distillation and
the main changes are highlighted in
green
so I'll go through them step by step
so in Progressive distillation we start
out with a trained teacher model so the
way I've written it here is it's a
prediction of the clean data X and with
it using as input and noisy data as a
set t
at each iteration of progressive
distillation we do a warm start so we
say we set the students equal to the
teacher by copying the parameters
and then comes the interesting part so
the interesting part is where we set the
targets that we train the model against
and we determine that Target by running
two steps of the ddim integrator so ddim
is one way of integrating this ode that
I showed you in the past slides
um and it's the most efficient
integration that we have so we use two
steps on ddim to get you a next step in
the sampling chain
um then from that next step in the
sampling process we back out the the
targets that are our student model we
need to predict in order to get to the
same points in one step
so that's given by this formula and then
this target is what we actually plug in
into the the loss for the model so this
is what we ask the student model to
predict
so we do this for a number of steps
until we're happy with the results and
then the student becomes the teacher for
the next iteration of this algorithm and
we halve the number of sampling steps
so what we find is that this works quite
well in certain data sets and what I'm
showing you here is the FID for a
distilled model for varying number of
sampling steps and I can I'm comparing
it to ddim and to a stochastic Baseline
sampler drive that is separately
optimized for each number of sampling
steps so it's quite a tough Baseline to
beat
and we find that as you
decrease the number of sampling steps by
a lot and they still model does much
better and in particular we find that
four to eight sampling steps is kind of
the sweet spots where you don't lose
Mars in terms of quality
um but you do have a very large speed up
compared to naively taking as many as
5-12 steps in this case
so that was the first paper where we
showed this as a proof of concept on
image stats and on other data sets it is
more recent cvpr paper we extend this in
multiple ways so we showed that this
approach also works with classifier free
guidance we show that you can actually
use the distilled model to do stochastic
sampling not just deterministic sampling
um we show a little words for taxi image
models not just class conditional
generation
and we do image image translation we're
in painting and we show that this
actually also works for latent diffusion
models and so most of the samples that
you see in these slides are actually
generated using a distilled model or
stable
distilled version of stable diffusion
um I'll tell you a little bit more about
some of these aspects
um
so in particular and the way we actually
distill models with classifier free
guidance is in two steps in the first
step we take this classifier free
guidance model that actually takes two
Parsons in order to take one step in the
sampling algorithm and we distill that
into a model that only takes a single
pause
we do that by sampling a Gardens
coefficient so that's the the W
parameter I showed you earlier and we
sample this from a particular range like
between zero and four
then we find the
teacher prediction that corresponds to
that so we did two passes through the
the teacher model we apply the guidance
formula and we get a prediction out
and then we try and mess up with the
student model and the student model
takes us input also the guidance weight
w so in addition to the input data and
embedding of the time step it also takes
an embedding of the W parameter
so you train that for some time
after which you have a single model that
now does in a single step what the old
model did in two parcels
and after that you can just do the
progressive distillation that I
previously explained and so you're at
the number of steps that you're happy
with
um now we have a deterministic model
that takes many steps and previously we
only did deterministic sampling using
that approach so that corresponds to the
top of this uh this slide where in this
case we take for deterministic steps
I use it shown by the blue line
to get to the image and then we give us
output and it actually turns out that we
can also do stochastic sampling with
this and the way that works is that we
just simply double the step size that we
use for all these domestic steps so the
blue steps are twice as big but then
after each determinist accept forwards
we actually take a step backward by
adding noise back into the image
so adding those back into the image is
just exactly the same as what we do
during training we're taking a clean
image or a halfway clean image you add a
little bit of noise in
um and because we can actually split out
this sde into a deterministic part and a
a noisy part
um you can actually show that this is a
very this is actually also a very uh
Accurate Way of sampling from this
process
and what we find that this is
particularly useful for cases where we
use high guidance weights
um lots of lots of numbers here I'll
show you two in this red box here so in
this red box on the left you see the
number for the deterministic sampler the
Inception score that you achieve with a
deterministic sampler using eight
sampling steps and then guidance way to
four and the right number in the red box
is the same number you get by doing
stochastic sampling
we find this is generally a bit higher
when using uh
when using a few steps in high guidance
weights
um and so this uh and this also
translates to images that we find a bit
more compelling
um yeah finally what we find is that
this is directly this algorithm is
directly applicable to latent diffusion
models like stable diffusion
um so uh channeling the first author of
the paper apply this to a stable
diffusion where you can get quite good
results using as few as two sampling
steps
so to summarize uh the talk so far
um I think generative models are really
no longer just a science projects when I
got started in this field I clearly were
um I mean no one is going to use the
samples on the left here but now we're
at the points where these models
actually produce quite amazing things
um and I'm I'm confident so they will
end up in lots of products in the coming
years and will be very impactful
diffusion is becoming quickly the new
paradigm
um for achieving state-of-the-art
results using generative models
um it's a very flexible framework it's
it's stable it's not like again where we
don't really have a proven convergence
it's a that's more of an empirical
science but really we have a simple loss
term that we can and that we can
minimize and use the trainer model
and finally I believe strongly that
these moles need to be fast if we
actually are going to use them and
um our approach to that has been
distillation and that's been proven very
effective so far
right thanks I can now take some
questions
foreign
this was my first time seeing
distillation outside of Transformers
honestly I really like the idea and the
intuition behind it
and we have a bunch of questions
so Patrick is asking and not sure how
much Tim can talk about this but I'm
very curious if Imogen would have
similar performance if it would would
have been trained only on public data
um right so
data is of course very important
um
there's a lot of data out there on the
internet I'm sure you could get similar
Performance training just on public data
but then the question is how do you
curate the data
um so just taking every random jpeg you
can find on the internet that won't work
you need to put some time into actually
selecting the right ones and if you do
I'm sure it can work and um
you know at Google we're definitely
exploring lots of different data sets
and finding that different data sets are
appropriate for different purposes
um but that yeah good results can be
achieved in every variety of ways
and the second question is can we do the
same with all types of noise or
distortions not just gaussian also is
the noise required to be uniform over
the entire image or can we have areas
with more noise than others right that's
a good question so there are some words
in literature where they do use
different types of noise but in general
all of our results do depends on this
infinite divisibility of the noise so
one thing that's very unique about the
gaussian is that if you add two
gaussians together you still get a
gaussian out
or a quick the other way around if I
give you the noisy data you can actually
decompose this into a number of additive
noise terms at all that are actually
consistent with the output distribution
so there's ways of doing something
similar with different distributions but
it's um
it's it's quite tricky to get something
that's theoretically Justified so I
would say in general yes it needs to be
gaussian and what we do find is that you
can actually add more noise in in
certain directions than in others
and we actually have a paper called
blurring diffusion models where we do a
transformation of the image very
effectively we're adding noise in
particular directions more than it
matters and this also works quite well
yeah I will Emil talked about it a
little yesterday because people were
asking about it
and
our third question is from Patrick
people are playing around with using
character-based text encoders now such
as byt5 or K9
uh hoping that they are better at
generating exotic text what do you think
about this
right so so what we do find is that if
you wanted to be able to do spelling
like in this uh this last example that
I'm showing you then of course you do
need to actually represent the
individual letters in in your embedding
um so big Tech models like T5 already do
that quite well but I I imagine that
doing character based encoding actually
is even better if that's what you care
about
um yeah there might be a trade-off the
trade-off though between
um
capturing the feel of an image and
exactly representing a prompt so
something like a clip-based encoding
like in Dolly 2 and also in some other
things that we tried
um
that is actually quite effective for
capturing the general feel of a prompt
so in italy2 paper there's some very
nice examples of that where they take a
logo they encode it and they generate
multiple logos that's kind of the same
um and that's something that I'm not
quite sure you would get from an
embedding from a text mobile that has
never seen visual data
another question is this sequential
approach with many large blocks seem
quite expensive they didn't notice much
poorer inference times for video Imogen
um so as I mentioned for for Imagine for
for video imagine for the the base model
where we take
seven different steps seven different
diffusion models
um and we use 256 to 128 steps to to
sample from them it does take over 10
minutes to generate a short five second
video so that is indeed quite slow
so there's different ways of speeding
that up
um one approach to the distillation that
I talked about here another is the the
one that Emil photo out yesterday and
where rather than having a sequence of
multi-resolution models we're actually
trying to generate at the highest
resolution from the start we can
actually do that quite well now
mainly by making some changes to the
noise schedule that we use for sampling
um and this is definitely something that
we're still working on and I think these
modes will get faster and more efficient
um
as we make progress there
another question is at what video length
assuming the memory allows for it to do
the video videos become inconsistent
right right
um that's a good question so in a video
diffusion models paper we also present a
way of Auto aggressively extending this
video
um so there's advantages to generating
the whole video in one go which is what
we do in the Imagine video but then if
later on after training for five second
videos you decide to actually want them
to extend the extended you can actually
do that using these models
um so this is a proven concept we
actually try doing this and generating
like minutes long video for for a
particular text prompt and it does
actually work quite well we don't we
don't really ever diverge
um
it's
just the alignment between the text
prompt and the video can deteriorate a
little bit so for example if you're
generating a person lifting an item from
the table then the first five seconds
with high guidance that's exactly what
happens then if you extend that video
you know you see like a person with a
object in their hands like standing
around a little bit and it's not that
interesting
um so you don't think I've gained that
much from it
um but it's it's certainly possible and
it doesn't diverge and that's that's
quite a nice property of these models
and we can have maybe two more questions
let's see
um
do you I think this is a good question
do you imagine that Progressive
distillation could be adapted to the
distillation of models in other fields
right right
um
yeah so that's a very General open
question
um
so these diffusionals though have a very
specific structure where they take many
steps to generate something that we
actually know deterministically
um and that that allows you to then
amortize taking all the small steps into
something that takes one large step so
amortization is something that is used
extensively in machine learning so for
example in alphago you might take many
steps to arrive at a particular move on
a go board or or on a chessboard or
something similar and then you can train
your neural Nets to cast that move from
the start without going through this
whole search process so I think
intuitively that's actually very similar
to what we're doing here
um
and I'm sure you know that the basic
concept is applied to many different uh
applications in machine learning
um in in another Fields uh and and yeah
hopefully Progressive distillation can
be an inspiration for for trying even
more applications
I would imagine and for uh stuff like
alphago it would be quite expensive to
get somewhere though
yeah I mean that but that's true right
like in an off ago also the computers in
search or in every search that we
evaluates in the neural Nets and if you
search very deeply
um
then the the base model that you or the
first time you evaluate the model that's
only very small it's not part of the
compute but then what they find in their
case is that if you train is well enough
then even the first step is pretty
decent and this is similar to how our
distilled model is still very slightly
worse than the base model but it gets
you most of the way
um
so let me see if there is like a cool
question there is like a lot of cool
questions but I'm trying to pick the
best one because we will host surai soon
um
you say that diffusion become the
dominant Paradigm and I agree do you
think the recent consistency models
could become the nail Paradigm One Two
Step without distilling
right so the the recent consistency
models paper I quite liked
um
like mentally I still place this into
the diffusion Paradigm it's uh very
closely related and I actually think
that there are strongest results roles
are still distilling from a trained
diffusion model so their Paradigm does
allow for training from scratch but the
best results that he achieved were still
using distillation
and the Boris is asking is a pipeline of
multiple models necessary or could you
use a large model end to end
so using a large model end-to-end is
something that we've explored and that's
Emil talked about yesterday so I'm sure
you can still see that talk also
um it is a bit more tricky to to train
as correctly but we're making a lot of
progress there
um yeah once again you need to adjust
the noise distribution and maybe also
adjust the model
um but I believe we can indeed train one
big model
and this was the last question I really
liked your presentation thank you so
much for accepting to speak today
thanks for the opportunity thank you see
ya bye
and now I will be hosting Suraj from
hugging face and he will be talking
about mask generating models which was
something that I was very curious about
would you like to share your screen
yes okay can you see it
um yes
let's go
okay I will leave you with your
presentation good luck thanks Mary
all right hi everyone I'm Suraj I'm a
machine learning engineer at chugging
place and I mostly do open source stuff
all the commentator of Transformers and
then now I'm a commentary of defeaters
and I'm mostly working on open source XP
image models
so today
I'm going to talk about this new method
for image generation using discrete
tokens
to which is like a which was recently
proposed by Google and it's called mask
generative models so basically it's a
Transformer based Master language model
that can do really good image generation
and the papers like musket and Muse have
established state-of-the-art results on
some image generation tasks at the time
of publication
so this talking I mean I'll briefly talk
about why do we need these models and
what are the limitations of current
models and then I'll briefly present
what Muse is and then we'll go deep into
how these models are trained and how to
do inference with these models
So like um I mean as like everyone knows
that the most dominant approach for
image generation right now is diffusion
models we really don't need any
introduction for it and another really
popular approach before diffusion was
Auto regressive Transformer models you
know like the first Dolly model and then
Dolly mini and party
which he uses like a two-stage approach
where there's a VQ gun which can take an
image you can create a discrete
representation of it and then we use a
Transformer model and encoder decoder
Transformer model that can Auto
regressively generate the image tokens
by doing cross attention or the text and
especially if party has like really
really great results on these models
but uh one of the limitations of both of
these approaches is that these models
are slow at sampling time okay one side
note here that this the diffusion field
is very fast moving and then we we have
some new methods like consistency models
and distillation which can bring down
the sampling Time by by a lot but right
now I say for example if we take stable
diffusion we need to do like at least 20
or 25 steps to get good Generations if
you have Auto regressive model like
Dolly mini or party and if you when
you're generating 256 tokens then the
model you need to run the decoder for
256 forward passes so it's like the the
inference cost increases by a lot and
especially if you want to do high
resolution generation or video
generation then that becomes a
bottleneck
so instead these masking models like
musket and Muse offer like a more
efficient approach compared to this
these other methods they use a
bi-directional Transformers and these
models because of the way they are
trained they are able to predict
multiple tokens simultaneously like like
predict multiple tokens in a single step
and that way like they can accelerate
the decoding so instead of having to do
like 256 steps you can do like four
steps that steps or 16 steps depending
on the kind of quality you want from the
image so that's kind of a more
motivation for these models so now we'll
go over like how mask each actually
works so musket stands for like mask
generate you image Transformer and like
the first Dolly and the party model it's
a it's a two-stage model
so the first stage is a VQ model I won't
go into the details of VQ models here I
think you can look into taming
Transformers or there are lots of cool
resources for understanding VQ models
but basically what it does is like the
VQ part also has an encoder and decoder
the encoder takes an image and then
creates a discrete representation of it
so like you get like discrete integer
tokens and the decoder can take those
discrete tokens and turn them back into
the image and then there's another
Transformer model which is a bird like
mask Transformer model
and the way we train this model is we we
get these discrete representations and
then we mask a bunch of tokens in the um
from the input for example here the gray
tokens are mask tokens and then we feed
it into the Transformer and then the
Transformer is strange to predict these
mask tokens let's get two stage approach
say this is the VQ stage and there's the
decoder stage this but the decoder is
not Auto regressive it's it's a masked
language model but it's a must model
it's not so language
so during training uh musket learns to
predict randomly masked tokens by
attending two tokens in all directions
like this is one of the key thing here
for example image images kind of have
bi-directional tokens it's not like
language where
the where the future tokens only depend
on the past past tokens and the past
tokens are not influenced by Future
token but like in images like you you
have bi-directional dependencies
is like instead of using a causal musket
you just since it's a mask model it uses
a bi-directional mask so each token can
attend to every other token so it in a
way it has more context and then at
inference time uh we start with all
masks tokens and then the model keeps on
predicting the mask tokens and then we
keep on iteratively
improving the improving the generation
that's kind of the basic overview of
musket
now uh during training what we do is as
I said it's a two-stage model we use a
VQ model encoder to get a discrete
representation of token and then we
sample a subset of tokens and replace
them with a marks token this is the key
part here
um for example if you are doing Mass
language modeling in NLP for so there's
bird you use like a fixed masking rate
of 15 and you mask like 15 percent of
any random tokens but in in musk each or
in Muse what we do is we use a
scheduling function and that scheduling
function tells us how many tokens to
mask
so the masking we do here is a variable
we don't like we don't have a fixed
masking rate of 15 percent
because to this is to be able to like to
emulate the inference scenario
we use a variable masking red so the
model can see like what to do when all
to concern Mass what to do and like some
partial tokens are masked
and which which is a really key thing to
get this model to work to use a variable
masking rate
and then the model is trying to predict
these miles tokens by attending to all
the tokens and Martin this like apart
from the like the scheduling function
the musket training is exactly similar
to how you would train a bird model so
but instead of the language tokens you
have the discrete tokens of image given
by the week you can you use a variable
masking schedule for example for one
example you would mask 40 in another
example you would mask all of the tokens
for some examples you would mask like
just five percent ten percent on one
percent of the tokens and then the model
is trained to predict these mask tokens
and then during decoding as you can see
in the image what we do is we kind of
fix the number of steps for example we
say like we are going to do the
inference in seven eight steps or 16
steps and then when we we are starting
the generation at at t 0
we start with all mask tokens
then feed that input into the model and
then we then the model predicts those
mask tokens and then we choose some
tokens which have like a bit of a higher
probability for example you check this
like the dark gray area here is the
token selected at that time step and
then we keep on iteratively doing this
like at each iteration we select some
tokens which have a which have a high
probability
and then we mask out the remaining
tokens and keep on doing this generation
so at the last steps when we are here we
then once we have like a lot more tokens
generated we just at the last step we
predict like all the remaining tokens
and then we have our final image
also the key thing you notice here is
that when we start the generation the
number of predicted tokens are very less
for example in the first step there's
just one token then here like seven or
eight tokens but as we get more context
we choose like multiple tokens which
sample multiple tokens that's because
the model has more bi-directional
context
and to to introduce the diversity in
generation we use temperature and
healing so like instead of choosing the
token with the highest probability we
just we say we set a certain threshold
and depending on the like from that
threshold we just randomly sample some
tokens and this helps the model to like
retain diversity in in regeneration
and um yeah so that's pretty much how
training and generation with uh must get
works and another cool thing apart from
these models being fast is that these
models due to their nature of training
support a lot of image editing tasks out
of the box for example they can do zero
shot in painting or outputting they can
do image extrapolation and zero shot
mask free editing like because the the
model is trying to predict mask tokens
you can to do in painting you can just
like mask certain only mask out the
tokens in The Mask region of the image
and then ask the model to predict those
and it it works pretty good as you can
see in these examples
again the key thing here is that these
models are not trained to do in in
painting out painting or like mask
pre-editing it's just due to the nature
of the nature of training of these
models they can like zero shot they have
the zero shot ability to do in printing
Out Printing and mask free editing
and the next step of musket is Muse
which is basically like a musket model
but it's for text to image conditioning
so it has a text encoder
uh as a conditioning and then the model
text like as musket it takes the mask
tokens but also does cross attention
over the text embeddings
to to generate the image and Muse is a
two two State models so the first stage
generates the 256 by 256 image and then
in the second stage it's also
um very similar to the first stage but
it has two contexts it takes the
text the generated low resolution
generated tokens from the first stage
and also the text embeddings and they
does cross attention over both of them
and then generates a high resolution
image
and one of the reasons we don't directly
generate 512 512 images because
sometimes the model can generate high
frequency details
so it's so instead we choose the two
stage approach
and the results with Muse model are
really great these are some of the text
to image samples
this is some of the zero shot mask in
painting
and this is mask free editing like you
just provide an image and just
mask a bunch of tokens from that image
and then just give any prompt and the
model has the zero shot ability to edit
it according to the prompt without using
a mask
yeah
and yeah so it's it's all great but it's
it's not as with like other Google text
image models it's not open source which
is just kind of not a good good news
because it's when the models are not
open source like the community can try
out the models it's very hard to
evaluate the models it's very hard to
understand the capabilities of the model
and for example evaluating models is
notoriously hard like the current
metrics like FID or clip score don't
completely capture the capabilities of
model or instead like if we give the
model out to the community to try it out
and like do different kinds of
generation use different types of
parameters and what notes we can like
very easily assess the qualities of the
model find out different biases one of
the great examples is stable diffusion I
mean like everyone has seen like
explosion of stable diffusion and most
of the the things that we can do the
community has done with stable diffusion
also most of these now go there a
current like a lot of methods like tune
a video or control net are now based on
stable diffusion so it's because like
that single model was open source a lot
of new methods and applications came out
of it
so and so in the spirit of open
reproduction at hugging Pace we have
kick-started a project to openly
reproduce Muse
and we are collaborating with Robin
Romberg the creator of stable diffusion
and the open source Community to openly
reproduce and train views model and then
along the way share all artifacts code
and learnings with the community so the
community can build on top of it we have
open source the code at this GitHub URL
and all the intermediate checkpoints
will be available on the Hub as as we
train them so far we have two models
just class conditional models to to test
the approach and so far it's been going
well and and the plan for the next
couple months is to scale up the model
and train it on bigger data sets so stay
tuned and if you have any any feedback
just go to the repo and share your
suggestions or if you want to interact
or if you want to join the efforts just
feel feel free to just come in there
it's it's going to be all open source
so yeah that's it for me
hello I I really liked the idea
um it's it's very often that when you
are like um when you are training masked
models in text uh like you only can
learn about the distribution of things
but like you cannot really do the stuff
like
I don't know how it would work for
um textbook like in painting and out
painting with mask uh masking is like
very intuitive and I really liked it
I had this question but it's it was like
a bit of a stupid question because like
apparently when you do masking it's like
it's it's it's like
um masking in the like when you are
masking patches and other stuff it's not
like you don't have bi-directionality
but you have non-directionality actually
I think
it's a
I mean I'm sorry I didn't get the
question so like you directly feed the
so basically you you mask the tokens and
then you directly feed the
the thing itself like the masked image
itself right yes yeah that was why I was
saying it's not really bi-directional
it's like non-directional actually like
you don't really
try to predict the next thing or like uh
yeah it's a bit like birds
yeah exactly so
um we have like a couple of questions
it's
um Alex is asking once a token is
unmasked can it be changed again say
mask token
Arrow token X Arrow of token y I don't
know
I think uh ideally it can but the way we
train these models
it's just like once a token is predicted
there's we don't have a surety that the
model will like predict another token
for that position it's also one of the
question I want to like do a bit of
research on as part of open music like
for example during training instead of
just replacing a token with mask can we
replace it with some random token so the
during inference we can we predict the
on like mask tokens again and then we
predict those
and another question is is it possible
to use other sampling techniques than
temperature based analogous to sampling
form from language models type K top P
or locally typical sampling
yeah yeah it's definitely possible to
use any of the top K or top B
so this is the sampling is very similar
to the way we do it in NLP
cool for now we are just using
temperature basically that's what was
proposed in the paper and we wanted to
kind of
um train the models and compare with
compare it with the paper so we kept
is is it like did you try to like infer
or are you still training is it hard to
get right
the the search parameters and like the
temperature top carry and more
it's like the default parameters
sometimes work but to get best
Generations I think you just need to
kind of do a hyper parameter search like
just choose a bunch of values for
temperature top gate of p and then just
evaluate the models
cool
um another question is does the future
steps can impact already unmasked tokens
or was it trained in a way that only
unmasked tokens Can impact future tokens
and not the opposite path
that's an interesting question
um
in a way like there's no future step
here because the model is bi-directional
yeah it does attention or or all the
tokens so both mask tokens can influence
unmaster contains and unmasked tokens
influence Mass tokens
yeah and that's what I guessed as well
so Christopher is asking can sometimes
explain to me like I'm five half
tokenization works for an image
um
that would be a different token itself
but I'll try to see if I can
find some slides
so the tokenization I think we use uh
Vector contacts vae or vector quantize
again here it's basically like a vae but
there's a discretization bottleneck
um so the basic idea is like once you
you have an encoder and then you get
some sort of embeddings there's an
embedding table and then the discrete
tokens are the tokens which are kind of
represent those embeddings and the model
is Trend in such a way that uh
um like as the model compresses the
image we it's able to find the nearest
embeddings using the tokens
I'm not sure if that makes sense I don't
have the slides for like any diagrams
for
a week you can now but I'm happy to
expel it on the repo if you ask the
question there
um Andreas is asking how different can
the unmasked king during inference be
from unmasking during training
how different
[Music]
um
like I think yeah
no I I just wanted to explain the
question
yeah I didn't get the question
completely
uh it's
I think Andreas clarified it a little
bit how different can the unmasking
strategy during infants be from the
unmasking strategy during the training
how does this impact quality of the
generated image
I haven't really experimented with it
and there are no details in the papers
as well so it's um I guess we will have
to find out
cool and this was the last question
thank you so much I really liked your
presentation
see you
and I can have Sabrina now
hello Sabina hey how's it going
good good
how are you
doing all right
um just came from a wild kayaking trip
that had to be awarded thanks to weather
conditions so we got to ride on a fast
fast boat with Park Rangers and law
enforcement delightful
um but yeah so that's why I'm in this
Airbnb with just my laptop so now funky
you choose green magic thanks a lot for
making slime to present today
yeah for sure
would you like to share a screen all
right let me do that
[Music]
there we go
do you see the slides yep perfect
wonderful I will leave you with your
presentation then good luck alrighty
thanks
hey so I'm Sabrina Mi okay I'm a grad
student at Hopkins
um hopefully finishing soon
um I've kind of spent my time writing my
thesis lately which is why I haven't
been doing that much new stuff with Jax
um and if you look at this a little
tagline here uh it says the slides are
almost two years old at this point
um and the blog post that it's all based
on is even older
um but we're going to get to that in a
second so the talk title is kind of a
mouthful from stateful code to purify
Jacks how to build your own Nelnet
framework
um and I guess it's somewhat of a
different talk
um than the ones that you've seen before
uh in that I'm not really going to be
describing interesting results New
models
um state of the art uh bleeding ads
things
um I really want to give you more of a
an insight and a bit of like a
uh hand holding to your own tinkering
with some of the Frameworks that you're
using in this workshop and other stuff
you might see in the Jax ecosystem
so
um when Jax first really became a thing
a topic people were interested in
um it was often described as like numpy
plus something so you might say it's
numpy plus jit so an implementation that
used to be on CPU like in this paper uh
some students and I wrote back in the
day
um you could have like an SK learn
implementation that was great 10 seconds
on CPU but you're like well we're in the
age of gpus can't we put this on the GPU
and with Jax well that's super easy you
just implement it call jit on it and run
it on your accelerator and you get some
nice speed ups that way
in fact when I started messing around
with it um I had this little thing where
I was like okay how fast can I make
lstms go because they weren't like
entirely dead at that point just yet
um and Jeff Dean actually retweeted me
and I'm so happy this is the highlight
of my career
um so you can have a lot of fun just by
making things fast with Jax okay fine
um but then interesting for us is also
of course the Grady I'm taking right if
we want to do something with Radiance
which we do that's kind of all we do in
a way
um it makes sense of Jax to think of Jax
AS numpy Plus gradient taking
um and this is not just your boring old
gradients you can do uh pretty wild
things like super easily um I don't know
how many of you are familiar with
reversible jump mcmc um if you're doing
like Bayesian sampling you might have
gone into mcmc and reversible jump is
kind of a cool way to change
dimensionalities but anyway I don't I
don't really want to talk about that and
you don't really need to look at all of
this code
um what I just want to highlight is that
the math says you need the Jacobian
determinant of a diffiomorphism and okay
you look that up you implement it a
little diffiomorphism that's just a
function like this
um okay it's literally just a python
function how do I get the Jacobian
determinant of that well with Jax I
literally just call the Jacobian uh get
this reversible Jacobian
then I get the determinant and voila
that's all I need
pretty wild
um like super convenient imagine having
to do the math nobody wants to do that
right
um so that's cool
um and then yeah you add your jid on top
of the grad and you v-map it or P method
and speed amazing
um you can do some very fun things with
that
but what I want to talk about
um here is more like if you're coming
from the previous age of Frameworks so
think Pi torch and eager mode tensorflow
um
once you look under the hood of how
these things work it gets kind of weird
you're like how where's the dot backward
and house is actually done and so how do
we actually
Implement a neural NET Framework or even
just train a neural net
um with this sort of Technology
to show the difference here's kind of
what you would imagine it would look
like in say apply torch if I take two
tensors let's say w and x and I multiply
them to create a new tensor y
um what the sensor Y is actually going
to have is not just the storage for the
data not just the number 546.
but it's also keeping track of where it
came from it's keeping track that it was
the result of this particular memory
object that is the tensor called W in
this particular memory object that's the
tensor called X oops there goes the chat
oh well
um
so this is kind of nice because now
every tensor knows where it's coming
from and so if you want to do a backward
pass well every tensor just goes to his
predecessors and so on right this is
what we can see here once we are calling
dot backward starting from the usually
the last note but just the final note of
your graph
um we reverse mode Auto diff by
following these connections and that's
propagate the gradients at the top all
the way down to the leaves where usually
we're interested in the gradients of the
weights
so that's how we work in pytorch you
build up your graph just by writing out
the math you call Dot backward and
whoops everyone everything has gradients
wonderful
um in Jax it's a little different
because everything is pure and we're
thinking a lot about transformations
what do I mean by that
um first of all what we're writing are
pure functions like this I've called
this function f very creative I know
um and it does the same thing we've done
before we just multiply these two
tensors w and X together
um we can draw a little picture okay
it's like two things go in no one comes
out wonderful
um and now if I want to get the
gradients in there what I do is I
transform this function I take just a
function f no values call Jack's grad on
it and it gives me a new function I've
called dftw
um it still takes the same inputs so it
takes the W and the X but now it gives
me the gradient of what used to be the
singular return value of x of f
with respect to W and X or by default
just with respect to W the first
parameter of a function so I've drawn it
this way
okay so great now that's that that looks
like what I remember from high school in
math you do derivatives that's yeah you
get a function now what
um how do I how do I work with this
right
um well I evaluate this function
using my current W and my current X I
mean imagine W being weight and X being
the data and I get the actual gradient
value which is in this case 42. the
gradient with respect to
W and that's the same as it was here in
the pi torch case that also gave me
everything else
okay
I'll do it I transform the function I
evaluate the transform function I get a
number that's my gradient or I get a
chance or that's my gradient
great that's that's some nice toy
examples um but but how are we actually
going to go from these three liners to
training a big neural network where it's
not just a function f that multiplies
its two inputs right or or said
differently how can weights and
gradients be stateful if our tensors can
be mutated
for those who are terminal the internet
brain or the form it appears in their
life
um so as I said this talk is based on
this blog post that I wrote in March
yeah that's right March 2020
um it's like multiple lifetimes ago
wasn't it
um and so you might be like wow that's
that's that's great that's really
exciting
um we're getting like the reheated
leftovers
um human ass is still relevant
um and the answer is no it's it it never
was relevant in the sense that it never
really dealt with like oh
state-of-the-art things this is
idiomatic code this is cool results
um it's really like our post you could
have written a long time ago
um just just about the theory of it
um but something that people are now
interested in because all these big
Frameworks are out there and we want to
maybe contribute to them or just
understand what they're doing
um and I found it really hard to
understand what they were doing when I
started out with Jax so that's kind of
where this is coming from um hope after
this talk um it'll all make a lot more
sense to you and you're not gonna have
to trial and arrow your way through it
like I did
so what are we going to accomplish again
there will be no no shiny funny things
to look at no eye candy there's no going
to be any idiomatic allergens I will not
claim that my coding style is the right
one just kind of works and small enough
that they shouldn't be too much wrong
with it and we're also not going to do
many of these cool things that I was
talking about earlier we're like yeah
you can batch distribute and compile
um because it's kind of orthogonal to
what we're trying to achieve and you
could always add it on top
while we are going to do though and
finally I'm saying something positive we
are going to be looking at the dead
simple example of linear regression good
old MX plus b
um we're going to do it statefully so
like the pytorch way try and train it on
some data and you know okay just
reminder how we used to think the
software then we're going to be trying
to move this example to Jax while
dealing with this notion of Purity that
is required for a gradient taking there
I'm gonna have a little aside you can
get a coffee if you're not that
interested
um where we're kind of like um what if
actually we could do this cool thing
that people don't do but you could do
um and then we're going to be working
towards the actual foundations of a
framework that kind of does the work
that we did in step two for us
and finally we're going to find out oh
that's that's what these Frameworks do
all along big surprise sorry I spoiled
it
so here's what a mod should look like in
pytorch I don't know how many people
still remember I feel like I have
forgotten
um I literally had to like watch a
recording of this talk yesterday last
night being like Oh yeah yeah that's the
stuff that's right
um
but what you see is essentially that
modules own their weights there are
these parameters which are just wrapped
tensor objects
um and they're assigned to this unit
this lstm cell and then in the forward
method you use um when you build this
execution graph this tape that we've
seen before
um so far so good um once you do like
your actual training Loop what you're
going to be doing is create your
instance instantiate all the weights and
then call Dot forward which uses the
current weight dot backward which starts
this whole process of going backwards to
the graph right and writing out all the
gradients everywhere and then once we
have gradients on all our Leaf notes
apply them to the data like if this was
the middle SGD
um and that's basically how you would do
it um unlike the most Bare Bones way
with play torch
if you mutate the gradients by calling
last step backward and you mutate the
weights by calling parameter data minus
equals
and both of these things are no longer
allowed once we move to Jax
now I'm going to switch to the notebook
part and I hope you can you can still
see this and I hope my runtime hasn't
died
oh no but this runtime has died well
that's no good everything seems to be
fine except for the runtime okay
wonderful wonderful all right by the way
I I wanted to just comment that I wish
they actually would teach deep learning
Frameworks like this in schools like
I've been enjoying your talk a lot
um
okay
um thank you
I try to get it to comic comic code
ligatures again this is one of my
favorite coding fonts but I guess it
only lasts up one cell
depressing what can what are we gonna do
some some people are asking if you could
make the phones bigger
oh right
let me do that yeah how's that thank you
yeah it looks good thank you
all right so this is the the thing that
I just said um we're doing linear
regression we're doing it on Torch we're
being a very boring
um we have our weights they're being
owned blah blah blah production users
self dot something we have a loss
function in this case just root mean
squared error that again uses
um the parameters that are owned by the
module blah blah blah number comes out
let's create this object
um and then let's test it out for a
second
does it predict for the number three
well it predicts zero which makes sense
we've initialize the things to zero
right zero times zero plus zero zero
times three plus zero is zero wonderful
how how exciting
um Let's do let's do some training
though
um
we're going to create a very small data
set as literally just one example that
three should be map to seven
[Music]
um and since we already know that three
is mapped to zero what do we expect the
root mean squared error to be
that should be seven
um so far so good
um
so now that we have a loss that works we
can do a little bit of training so let's
make the data set a little bigger so
we're not like totally under defined
um you can make out in your head what M
and V fit this one
um but it should be fairly
straightforward let's just train this we
get the loss we backward
we go through the parameters we have the
gradient blah blah blah we do this
little step that when I learned this
stuff I always love to forget and wonder
what my networks didn't train properly
and then hopefully we're going to see
this prediction come closer to the true
answer which is seven
and let's see
voila yes wonderful it goes there it
doesn't really hit seven or step size is
too large we should be smart with it but
we don't want to be smart we just want
to be smart enough for this talk that's
going to be enough
okay
so that's the pie charts example just to
refresh your memory you can come back
from your coffee break now because we're
going to be looking at it in Jax
this is how you might try to implement
this thing in checks you're like okay
I'm gonna make a class I'm gonna make
weights and stuff they're going to be
owned by the module predict and then we
do the rmse yup yup cool very similar
nothing interesting happening here
um let's let's see what happens uh on
this one we should predict zero yup and
we should have a loss of seven yep so
far so good it's a very direct
translation
um but now we're going to start running
into issues because now we need to get
gradients right what do we take the
gradient off
well we usually take the gradient of the
loss function right the loss function is
RMS e
um and things get a little weird here
because this function is not at all Pure
or at least
um it doesn't make sense to think of it
as a pure function because it takes the
entire object
and differentiating with respect to a
python object seems a little weird
so before I go even further into this
discussion of Purity that just sounds
very strange and we're not on the same
page what it means let's go look at some
examples
um I've written down three functions
here and already given away the answers
the first one is pure second one impure
and the third one pure again and I want
to illustrate some things on these
functions basically a pure function the
idea is something goes in something goes
out that's all the function does it
doesn't mess with any of the other stuff
that's around in the ambient atmosphere
so for the first function that certainly
is true we put a number in and twice the
number comes out
nothing has been mutated or illegally
accessed
mutation is why the second function is
no longer pure because if I call it it
is going to actually change the list
that I'm giving as an argument
so to illustrate this let me Define a
list down here L
um and call impure function
1 on l
well and let me do it again
results has changed in fact it has
changed uh oops not excess l
in fact we can see very clearly that L
is no longer the same so this function
is like evil it took something and then
it didn't do stuff with it and got
something else out no it took the list
that I gave it and messed with it that's
a no no
um it's also kind of easily spotable by
the fact that you call this function
twice with what was supposed to be the
same input and you've got different
results
a lot of sketchy stuff
on the other hand
um this function over here this pure
function also gets a list and also does
some list magic but it only appends
internal state so it defines this new
variable Ys and that variable you can
append stuff that's fine you can return
the variable for all you care you know
as long as you don't mess with your
arguments and don't mess with anything
that's outside of the function
everything is fine
and we can see that that's true
um like calling the function multiple
times gives me the same result
and the original list is still the same
it was
that that looks pretty pure to me
so that's nice
um let's do some more examples uh
here's some more impure functions that
are a little more interesting to look at
and while we look at these functions I'm
going to look at the chat
since my phone fell down
okay cool
um
yeah
what's wrong with these functions well
for one I've already talked about this
ambient State nonsense and this impure
function too very obviously mutates
Global stage right
does this it drags the number executions
variable from the global State into the
function changes it and then sure it'll
join something but it sounds something
evil inside we can see that that's true
just by executing it a bunch of times
we're like yeah I mean technically it
Returns the same number every time
but it changes this state it changes
This Global variable
that's bad
that's not okay
so now here's a question for you what
about this third function impure
function three
uh sorry that's not that's not my
example just yet um input function three
I can I can quickly show you that's also
sketchy
um because
call it
sure it gives me something but then uh
if I call it with a different Global
state
or executions I said right
if I call it with a different Global
state it suddenly gives us a different
answer
so that's bad and we don't want that
um
I was going to say something what was I
going to say
who knows kind of been that important
okay
so Global state that don't mess with it
don't access it okay it's fun
I'll be getting to my
sorry on one laptop screen I have like
my copy paste pad really tiny to the
side so I can't see what's coming up
this is very exciting
um
okay here we go final examples thank God
right back to some fun Jack stuff in a
second
um here's another Classic this impure
function does a lot of bad things that
are somewhat if you've ever used like
Haskell or some other functional
language like you know all this stuff
and you know these things are a little
tricky at first like you know printing
something out it changes the global
State what I see in my console window or
whatever is part of the global state so
this is already changing things
asking for the user input
um that's definitely impure like I could
I could put in something different every
time and the results of this function
might change that's no good the function
must only take in information that it
was explicitly given in its arguments
and finally this one here we're asked
for the current system time that's
obviously also a bad idea right because
that's going to change from execution to
execution we're again accessing
something we're not allowed to access
so now one last function mpo function 5.
which constraint does this violate
what's wrong with it
um it's impure I've given that much away
um
but what is it actually doing that's
kind of a
yeah let's see I'm gonna I'm gonna wait
a few seconds uh to see if someone
wants to DARE guess in the chat
um I also don't know if I
see the chat
it won't go down yes okay
yeah yeah that's the that's the
that's right Wow first try damn I like
when people struggle you know I like
when they get things wrong it's much
more fun
um but yes so it acts as Global stage
accessing the the seed and the state of
the RNG and it also mutates the state of
the random number generator right it
advances to the next stage so it can get
a new Fresh random number
um so it kind of violates both these
things of taking in things it wasn't
supposed to look at
and taking and having effects that it
wasn't supposed to happen
like the the the nature enthusiasts
among us might be familiar with the take
nothing but memories leave nothing but
Footprints and that's kind of kind of
applicable here in fact
um one mnemonic that I found super
useful um for understanding Purity and
for having like a very quick and easy
test is this one
the function you're implementing could
easily be a lookup table or it could
easily be cached
then it's pure
this is obviously not true for this one
right if I if I give it like a nice cash
decorator uh wow now my function is
cached and all the randomness is gone
um so that's not true same for these
things right I can't just cache user
input or Cache the printing because it
has to happen again when I call this
function
on the other hand or do we have a nice
pure function over here this function I
could totally cash that right it's never
going to change doesn't really depend on
anything else
so that's a really nice and easy way to
tell whether your function is pure if
you can convert it to a lookup table or
you can cache it
it's pure
okay
so
how are we going to do this is the time
jump back to the slides yet who knows
we'll find out
um how are we going to build the last
function that is pure
we do it like this
we are still using this weird object
oriented skeleton that we had up here
right where it owned its own way it's
um and it's used Eminence method
but just like our Pure example we're
past the list and then created our own
list that only mutated things inside
this will be a pure loss function right
yes it creates a stateful class and then
it mutates the stateful class and then
it calls the stateful class that
accesses its own thing statefully
but in the bigger scheme of things if I
just look at this function well it just
takes W and V and axis wise
and put some in there
and then calls this result and then the
linear regressor is destroyed afterwards
no trash is left we don't look at
anything we're not supposed to look at
so this loss function would be pure
and again the gives us gives us the
result that we wanted
you can use this last function in fact
to already start training this thing
again let's expand our data a little to
make it less underdefined
um here's a loss function we pass the
stuff in it's very beautifully pure
um and we take the gradients
um with with respect to the first two
parameters that's what this is for
because usually grad only gives you the
gradient for the first parameter but we
want gradients for w and for B so we
tell it give us gradients for both of
these things and that's what's coming
out DW DB
okay and now uh we have this this class
my regressor that we kind of keep around
statefully that's okay we're kind of
we're not letting Jack smell Jax doesn't
deal with this this is like our own
record keeping
um and we can mutate it again doing this
very simple SGD
um and then predict with it
and we see again trans beautifully gets
close to seven that's all we want that's
all we were asking for
okay
now if you give me a second I'm sneakily
looking at my phone to see when I'm
jumping back to
so okay no not for a while neat you get
to see more notebooking love it
um okay
so this is nice and all but
um it's kind of silly to have this this
my regressor class and not use its
function and just use it to hold the W
and the B for our own bookkeeping right
that's what we're doing here like we
might as well not bother you know screw
this you could wear this and let's store
our parameters in a nice dictionary
you know there's no much of a difference
except the dictionary feels lighter and
better and more modern and Sleek love
that so um with this we might change our
method slightly to now have our Pure
loss function not get W and B
or in other words not enumerate
parameter by parameter of our parameter
but only have this one dictionary params
and then still use it as before get the
W entry get the B entry calculate the
loss function easy peasy
um well function it's a little different
now because we still have access and
wires to the big data set that's fine
cool so we've saved ourselves a bit of
typing right up here that's that's nice
I'd love to save myself some typing
um but it gets even better
because now if you're asking yourself
okay well this is a pure function but
this is not a number how what the hell
is a gradient
for a dictionary
so what do you think if I do this if I
call jax.grad on the loss function now
again we're only interested in the first
parameters because we don't have to
Consolidated it
that gives me the gradient function and
I evaluate it on my current parameters
and my data set what's the type of
gradients going to be
now again we'll open up the chat
I'll give you a second
yes exactly it's a dictionary as well
dictionary that uses the same keys that
we've been giving W and B and the values
are now the gradients
calculated by jacks
and these are the same gradients we have
before and we're going to see them a
bunch more throughout this notebook so
um get familiar with these numbers but
yeah
um it just works like that this is
amazing right like in my loss function I
don't have to enumerate all the
parameters in here I don't have to
enumerate all the parameters in here I
don't have to enumerate all the
parameters the only place I ever really
deal with the parameters is when I use
them in my loss function
that's pretty cool
um and pretty convenient at that
so now with this we can we can again do
this thing where we update our current
parameters go through all these things
and if you're looking at this you might
already be like why don't you just Loop
through all the keys and and not write
things out line by line and patience we
will get there in just a second what
matters is loss goes down 7.5 goes to
6.1 amazing we've done it the machine
has learned
so I said uh we're going to get there in
a second and the second has come
um if we get our gradients like this and
we know their dictionary now right
um we could Define such a function
called like an update combiner this is
really if you think about it like a very
Bare Bones Optimizer skeleton
um which would take a single parameter a
single gradient like these could be
still be tensors they don't have to be
scalars but a single item
um give it a learning rate let's be
fancy so we really see what's happening
and it just Returns the new value of the
parameter which is parameter minus that
gradient just as before
and now what we can do is we can map
this update combiner over the tree in
this case it's just a dictionary but it
we're going to see in a second why it
could be called a tree
um
by passing it to this function called
jax.treymap
um together with the params and the
gradients and it is going to do this
work for us of going through all the
keys in this dictionary or all the
leaves in this tree
um updating them and giving us a new
object what is the type of my parents
kind of obvious at this point or at
least we would hope that it would be
something that we like
um it is a dictionary that contains a
new parameter estimates and indeed these
new parameter estimates that come out of
the update
again have made our laws go down wow
this is great
to update a question and chat that I
just saw
um by trees I'm going to mention in a
second uh what does weak type mean and I
wondered about the same thing when I
checked out this notebook this morning I
was like all right let's change some
Jackson's last time this wasn't here
um that's got to do with the type
promotion semantics so when I when I put
in something like
um yeah over here I say w is 0.0
what is that type something floating
point right but is it like
16 32 64-bit maybe it's even a complex
number
um just by writing 0.0 that's not really
specified and we could say like oh this
is actually an ah
an array with um
b-type something like oops can't type
and so on but um if we're not going to
do that um then Jack just like I don't
really know about this one let's say
this is a weak type for now that's
that's a gist of it maybe someone with
more uh experience working with this can
weigh in in the chat too
um but yeah I wanted the very same thing
um
this is something else I don't think so
right
cool so let's move on with that we've
made the loss go down we've used
jax.tree map which used to be called
jax.3 multimap you'll still see that in
the old blog post and stuff but it's
it's a small change
um you really just use it the same way
so that's wonderful
um
now that we've done some individual last
steps let's let the machine do this for
us we do a few steps of STD
um again this is all the same stuff
we've seen we take the gradient of the
loss function this we don't actually
have to use every Loop we could just
have done it once and then cache the
function but who cares go slow the world
is beautiful or something and then do
the treatment update
and this is a little awkward that we
still have this predict method coupled
to our linear regressor and now we have
to manually transfer the waves from the
dictionary into this object that holds
our magic methods but we're going to get
there in a second what matters is think
trains great
so we
so with this all done it is time for
an aside
uh so if you want to catch a break this
is it this is going to be a fun little
fun little thing that might help you
understand pie trees a little better and
someone already mentioned this in the
YouTube comments and I think it's one of
the most amazing and beautiful things in
Jax
um
you're wondering maybe why could we do
this thing with dictionaries how does
Jax know that it has to go through
dictionaries like some were in Jax it
says numbers are numbers tensors are
numbers dictionaries are close enough to
numbers they'll have like numbers in
them not good enough
um and the whole API is talking about Pi
trees as things that have numbers in
them that we can take out and do math
with
so you might really think of it as a
tree um this makes most sense in when
you think of like maybe a nested
dictionary writer dictionary that
contains some dictionaries that contain
some dictionaries that contain some
tensors and so Jax is somehow able to
maintain the structure
do things on the tensors in between like
take radians and then recreate this tree
with that structure with the new numbers
inside
and the Beautiful Thing is we can do
that too
um it kind of lets us do this where we
can register new types of Pi tree nodes
numbers tensors lists dictionaries and
our class linear regressor we're going
to make that a pi treature the way you
do that is you call Jack's free util
register proprietary node um give it the
class that you want to register and then
you give the two functions
these functions are pure because all
beautiful things are pure
um
are flattened and unflat
the flattened one basically takes this
complex object this Pi tree node that we
have and converts into a representation
that sort of tees us apart the two parts
of this structure whatever the whatever
the structure may be one part we call
the leaves is really a tuple or a list
of all the tensors in there the stuff
with the numbers the stuff that Jax is
going to be dealing with
and the other part concerns the greater
structure like if there's some
structural information that is not
numerical that we can't differentiate
through or anything like that but that
is important in this in this object and
must be kept for operations like tree
map
in this case since we only really have
these two scalos here I mean we just
make Leaves the Tuple and there's no
auxiliary information really
um when we return that Tuple that's what
you do for flatten and then for
unflattened you basically do the same
thing in Reverse you go from leaves and
auxiliary information back to the object
However unfortunately due to historical
baggage the argument order is reversed
right here so be careful with that
um again since we don't really use aux
I've just underscored it um we use the
leaves let's say it's Tuple wmd we know
this because we've created it ourselves
and then we create a new linear
regressor assign the right values and
return it
and so with these functions Jax can now
when it is asked to differentiate
through a linear regressor uh it can be
like all right I don't know what the
that is but uh let me call flatten
on this thing and then I get a tuple
with like numbery things that I do know
what to do with and auxiliary things
that I'm just not gonna touch
all right you do your thing on the
numbers now you call unflattened put it
all together and voila you have a new
linear regressor this is quite beautiful
magic in my opinion um I greatly enjoy
registering Pine notes Apache nodes all
the time and with this we can now do
cool things
um our last function can now take the
regressor as an object and do the rmse
um and okay that's fine we were able to
do that before but we weren't able to do
before is get gradients
so if I now call jax.grad last function
well we get a lot we get a function that
gives us the gradient with respect to
the first parameter which is my
regressor my class
so what's the type of gradients
what do you think
yeah it leaves the pi tree structure
basically untouched in the arcs thing
all that matters is that leaves is a
tuple or at least um I don't know if
that matters but I'll just make it a
tuple
um actually
anyway a tuple our list and
um that's all that's all you need to do
a tree yes it's a pie tree
um but what kind of pine tree is it
Ah that's right it's a linear regressor
right here
access created this class for us using
its magic and really using our hard work
of writing the flattened and unflattened
methods
that's pretty cool I think I don't think
so that's fine you can stay
um and we can look at these uh
properties of this object these these
members of our class and yes we get
these familiar gradients all has worked
out at before we can even do tree map
with this thing because tree map again
works with pi trees so we just combine
the original regressor with the gradient
regressor and we get a new regressor
and under that new regressor the loss
has gone down
so that's that's pretty much my side
um if you thought this was cool and you
want to see how far to take this
um you probably want to find a way to
automatically write flattening on
setting Logic for people's new classes
so they don't have to do this maybe you
use type annotations maybe you hijack
the methods kind of like pie torch oops
um and you want to do something with
initializers some Randomness and if you
follow this through you might get this
uh this little framework that Sasha rash
and I sketched in 2020 where we were
basically following this idea and seeing
how far we could get
um it's not really like been a thing at
all it's really just a fun project and
we kind of stalled on making batch
normal work because you are statefulness
um but if you want to take a look at it
you know that's there oh it could be fun
all right
so
um now let me think what do I switch
back
okay cool I think it's time to switch
back to the slides
oh less typing less room for mistakes
love to see it
um apple pie tree I love that
cool so um what we're going to be doing
next is forget about all these poetry
stuff that's what I'm saying it was
inside it was fun we had a good time we
had laughs but you know we still wake up
the next morning sober up and now it's
time to get back to work
um and actually think about what we can
do to make this dictionary based writing
or whatever we're doing just a little
bit nicer what we want to do is make the
user's life easy the user's gotten very
used to writing these stateful methods
like in pi torch
um I'm gonna say yeah fine write your
staple methods I'll clean up your mess
after
how do we clean up the mess
here's what we're going to be doing and
this is really the key idea behind these
Frameworks and behind this talk
um we're going to have this class
regressor as before it owns its weights
um and you know if this was ply torch
then this function f that takes in an X
yeah I would use the weights never
access State outside of the function it
should not be pure and return it's why
wonderful what we're going to be doing
is let the user write a class like that
but actually do a little trick
what we want to be doing is
um called a purifying regressor and I
totally made this up but I thought it
sounded pretty cool
um where we don't really start out with
a weight that's kind of weird there's
none here we'll deal with that later
um and the user writes this function f
just as before saying oh I access my
weight blah blah blah things will be
fine
um and then we are somehow tasked with
the job of creating a purified version
of that app
that now actually takes in the
parameters alongside the data first
thing it does is assigns of the W to
this information it just took in and so
now what happens when we next call this
dirty function f
is yeah we pass in the X we get out of Y
but when this function f acts as a
self.w
it doesn't actually access anything from
outside the function because we've just
defined solve the W to be the argument
itself
so the information flow doesn't leave
the function we don't actually violate
purity
because we've sort of tricked this
function it's running in a kind of
sandbox if you will
so after that I mean we might not bother
but I like to keep things clean
um we just set self to W Back To None
and we return the Y that came out of the
dirty function and as you can see all
the arrows are inside the function
nobody writes anything anywhere they're
not allowed to and nobody reads anything
from whether we're not allowed to
so that's pretty cool
um
and this is kind of how I want it to be
um I want to have this sort of fancy
magic artisanal base module class the
same way we have in all our favorite
Frameworks that's going to have to do
this work for us this purification
somehow I don't see it in my code that's
that's that's annoying and I want to
Define my impure function like in this
case we have an impure rmsa that takes
in the data so far so good
um and then uses its parameters now this
is not quite itself.w uh which maybe you
could make it work but it'll be much
easier to compromise on saying fine we
have like a method called get param that
sort of acts like self.w right we're
also going to pass this method and
initializer that looks kind of weird
like we're mixing things that wasn't
supposed to be mixed
um but we're going to see why that's
going to be really useful later on
and so now these W and B that we get
from get param we are legally allowed to
assume are actually just normal tensors
nothing weird about them so we use them
in our math and return on value
and something's going to happen here
there's got to be some magic that's
going to come from the fancy magic
artational base module class
um
and maybe it's called purify or
something we'll see we'll figure it out
you know we want to have a function that
basically purifies this impure function
into a purified function
and I'm already going to spoil we're
going to get an initializer out of this
that's why we mixed it up in there so we
don't have to enumerate like okay here's
our dictionary W zero V is zero um let's
just let's just like this function take
care of it you know why why make why
work when the framework can work for you
and then once we get my params that's
just going to be a dictionary just as
before
so you see that get param is actually
accessing this dictionary
um spoilers and so we can call a
purified thing with it we can do
gradients of the purified thing and call
that with it we can do Jack Stream app
and get new parameters just as we've
seen before okay
so let's implement this thing first off
to the notebook it says and that's what
we will do
here is my draft of what I want this to
look like we have the purifying
regressor it uses self.params as opposed
to self.getparam because you know let's
build this up simple let's not do the
initializer but just yet keep it simple
um okay this is great this is like what
I want to write because I'm boring and I
never want to learn new things and I
want to write pytorch code and
supposedly that's a good it's a good
thing to do
we have params initially set to none
and then this purified version of the
function set self.params to the params
that were passed called the emperor
function that tries to use self.params
but jokes on you there's nothing
actually you're getting that isn't
coming into this function to begin with
and then we zero it out in the end just
to be clean and return the result
initialize parameters by hand for now
get the value and graph because value
and grad is nice for what we want to be
doing when we look at the loss and the
gradients and the purify function you
will see is actually working because
yeah we can get gradients through it and
they are the same gradients we've been
seeing all along in this notebook
that's delightful
um
let's see
how can we make this this basically now
do the fancy or Crystal base magic
framework I would like to not buy too
much code well this one's going to be a
little bigger so I'm gonna decrease the
font size let me know what's a good uh
compromise
like maybe this will work
so
um since we're going to be doing
um pure execution and initializing I was
like super uber hyper careful and anal
about it and just added two flags to
this class that says are we running in
pure mode are we running an
initialization launch ideally they
should not be true at the same time
thank you there's better ways to do this
but yeah whatever it's good enough
um parameters are known as before here's
our function get param that I hinted at
in the slides and that is now going to
depend on which mode we're in if we are
initializing then we're going to check
do we already have that parameter in our
uh in our params dictionary
if so nothing we need to do if not
um create it with the initializer
um that's why we pass in the initializer
as the third argument to get param
okay and then return the parameters so
the function can continue
if we're running pure well then we
basically assume that the self.parents
has already been hijacked and we can
just use it so sure return self.parents
you know good for you enjoy
um and if we're not running and
initializing or in pure mode well then
we're impure and we don't like being
impure so we raise an exception
wow so much guardrail so much safety
feels very German
um
now we're going to have a bunch of
functions
um this one is basically the wrapper for
the initialization logic it gives us a
function called initialize params that
is returned that sets us to initializing
mode
gives parameters an empty dictionary
calls the method that it was passed
then when the method that Mayberry will
have been impure and we assume it to be
impure is done
we said initializing to false we return
self.params and we set self the params
To None to not risk leaking information
the bureau method works much the same
way and we've already seen this before
now where we create a new pure method
given an impure method called method we
said I'll be pure to true we set the
parameters up and we call the method
that is impure about jokes on you we've
already hijacked subtle params and again
zero it out after
and set the mode back to the original
one
the final one is the API that we want to
expose to the user so maybe I should
have underscored the other ones but I
hope you'll forgive me
um given a method
I want us to return a tuple that
consists of the purified version of the
method
and an initialized params version of the
method that basically is going to
initialize all the parameters and give
us the parameter dictionary
based on all the parameters that were
used in this method
that's a lot of stuff like this is a big
sell and if you're a little overwhelmed
I I understand but we're pretty much
done at this point with with the hard
lifting now we're just going to use it
um this is pretty much like what I
wanted to see in the slide we have an
impure RSM rmse use self.get param we
give it an initializer that's very
simple and boring we have an impure
project that also uses wmp and gets get
param the same way
um and then we call this purify that we
just defined up there and it gives us
the purified one and the initialize one
we call my params and let me actually
add this here because why not
we can see what's happening
and that's going to be
oh yeah yeah oh I didn't execute the
cell that would have been useful
so we should see the initial parameters
pop up in a second that should be zero
zero
um yep except we didn't have to write it
down the framework data for us
um and then we could get the loss before
the update we get the gradients we get
the laws after the update it's all
beautiful as it was before except we had
even less code to write and that's kind
of the beauty of it all
um again obligatory uh mechanization of
turning this into like a loop
our our loss goes down our correctness
goes up you know
and that's really all I'm going to show
you from this notebook to end this talk
with what kind of recap from what we
built we built this thing up here right
where we have a get param and we have
this purify and then we call initialize
and purified rmse
um but when we now look up over the
landscape of all these beautiful
Frameworks blossoming uh in the distance
we've kind of re-implemented exactly
what they're doing and this is Steve
Minds Haiku which was my framework uh
framework of choice at the time it
literally has a version a method called
get parameter and it gives it the
initializer and then it calls our purify
called transform and it gives you a
transformed in it and transformed apply
which is yeah which is our our
initialize params and our purify
function exactly the same thing a little
bit more Belton whistles to deal with
Randomness and state and all that stuff
but you know you get the idea
um yeah
or um more more appropriate maybe now
these days uh where where Flex has
become a big fan if you look at
Flagstaff linen
um it kind of uses this annotator and
out compact
um to do the transformation for us so
the class already uh turns its call
method into the init and apply pair but
apart from that again the same thing
happens we have this method called
shelf.param gets this name that accesses
the dictionary that's Underneath It All
We have an initializer in this case we
have a shape too
and then we have the internet and
applying same as we did well again with
Randomness handling which we skipped
over but you know that's that's that's
that's really all there is to it
so
um that's really all I have to say about
this we've kind of started From First
principles and tried to figure out how
could one do this and mess around with
some ideas and in the end we came up
with something that's pretty much
exactly
what the Frameworks are doing because
you know we all come up with the same
idea so often enough
so if you're interested in more details
about this more complications a little
bit more background maybe a slower
explanation
um I'll just more code this is all on my
blog post and there's a notebook
um version of it too and you can see the
slides of this talk and the recording
from back when and can compare how I'm
doing today
you can follow me on Twitter if you want
I'm not really active on Twitter anymore
these days it's one of the addictions
that I've actually
managed to replace so
yeah hey any questions and I'll be here
yeah there is one question because you
answered them throughout this Stream So
if we separate the parents dictionary
from the architecture how do we know
when the parameters are broken by a
change and architecture
mm-hmm so you would kind of Wonder like
how do I tell whether a dictionary is
compatible with the architecture that
it's using mind I mean I really think
that there's no no good answer to that
um like you could do something like okay
let's take the
um the architecture and like hash it and
store the hash in the dictionary that
that'll be a quick test
um maybe that's what some Frameworks
actually do I don't actually know I feel
like I vaguely remember something like
that but I'm not sure but even if not I
mean this is one of those things that
will
break it'll just break if you access a
parameter that isn't there
it breaks
um I I am of the opinion that things
breaking is a good thing I'd rather
things break than me
um but that's kind of what I would say
this is all about it gets a little
weirder when you have like parameters
that are in there but aren't used but
then the optimizer uses them so then
things get wacky
um but yeah I guess yeah like hashing
the architecture somehow is probably the
best way to go and again I don't know
what exactly Frameworks are doing
and Alex is asking with the gradient
being another linear regressor is
calculating the second derivative as
simply as just calling loss function on
the regressor again
um hmm
I don't see why not
um so what did we first Define this
[Music]
is all torch never mind uh you should go
a little beloved I think
[Music]
um
yeah here we go cool
um and this is what we have what we have
so let's add another cell
um
let's just call it Jack so grab twice
it's the worst that can happen right
um and
this is a function I'm gonna call it
separately with
I will pressure x's and y's
gonna happen well we'll find out
the functions all right so what we need
is uh okay
um so it's not really a gradient in this
point right it would be
um like a Jacobian or something
wait no no Second Assassin
something like that
um
yeah
yeah I wonder
you know I don't actually know no idea
maybe it's something obvious and easy
and I just don't see it right now but
that's a fun one
I don't think yeah we have any more
questions uh thanks a lot for this
presentation I loved it I will
definitely check out the follow-up
one uh Alex is saying you need to pass
the returns gradients into same function
returned by Jack scrub the loss function
um
I don't know how it is that should be
the same thing
um like
because loss function gives you a scalar
jax.grad gives you uh or executing
jax.grad gives you the linear regressor
so the type is messed up anyway yeah you
can't get a gradient with respect to a
regressor you could do it with respect
to all the individual leave node entries
or something
um
but I think I think really in this case
since we are dealing with like more than
scalars we are dealing with like
multiple Dimensions the second gradients
would not be gradients
um they would and should be something
something in quadratic
so Christian saying grad loss function
grad loss function
um
what would that mean
why would you run it over like that
that will be something but it would not
be the second derivative yeah yeah this
is different than the second derivative
I think
well I'm not the Jax Pro so and he is a
good one
it's acting on function without argument
so that doesn't work
Okay Christian is saying
not saying this is right and he says but
it will give something
it will give something that's for sure
yeah I think the types will work out on
that one that's true
um that looks like a good workout
yeah
anyway
um there is a Hessian function by the
way he says that makes sense I mean I
don't know how it works in this case
because we have multiple parameters that
are not in the same tensor so you get
some weird cross tensors
like the object wouldn't really match
right because you have these
interactions between W and B and they're
stored in different tensors so you need
like some WP and BW tensors so I think
it would get a little it will get a
little messy but I might be completely
wrong with that
who knows
so thanks a lot for coming today I
really enjoyed your talk and
um
so
um thanks a lot I'm going to take you
off now
see ya
um we are going to have another round of
talks on 17th and that will be the day
three of our talks and we have
speakers from Google brain we will have
a Boris who created the dalimini in the
previous Jax sprints and stay tuned and
also set your reminders for the day
three of them thank you so much for uh
chiming in and I will see you around
thank you